bili Eilish covers Rolling Stones August
issue and inside the mag she is opening
up like never before literally like I
stepped into my own brain now we're
breaking down the seven most shocking
things we learned from her big sit-down
starting with this Billy's first tour
included just six people and had a hotel
budget of one hundred dollars per night
that is sketchy
she told the mag quote it was miserable
we took it slow on purpose so it would
be more impactful when we got here but
we took it way slower than we needed to
the seventeen-year-old also got candid
about previously experiencing body
dysmorphia when she was a dancer I was
chubby and short and always worried
about my appearance I couldn't look in
the mirror at all
I mean that's why I wear big baggy
clothes eventually the teen had to give
up her dancing after she suffered a hip
injury which billy says took a major
toll on her mental health I think that's
when the depression started it sent me
down a hole I went through a whole
self-harming phase Billy says that ages
13 to 16 were quote pretty rough but
explains that she's in a much better
place now I'm like trying to enjoy it
then like not
complain because what is their complain
about I haven't been depressed in a
minute which is great
17 has probably been the best year of my
life number 4 on our list while Billy is
killing it on the music scene
I'm just hoping for the best she reveals
that she's gone on a few acting
auditions and she says she hopes she
gets to work with her mom and dad who
are both actors one day I actually want
to make a movie and put them in it I've
never told anyone that Billy also
reveals the very personal struggle her
family went through when they nearly
lost their home after the market
collapse in 2008 telling the mad quote
we were poor as number 6 Billy says she
has nightmares a lot sometimes you dream
about something and you might write it
down quote I actually had to stop
watching horror movies because
everything started flipping me out I saw
creatures outside my windows I had sleep
paralysis and last but not least Billy
opened up about experiencing synesthesia
the neurosensory wire crossing in which
senses seem to blend together quote
every person I know has their own color
and shape and number in my head but it's
normal to me for example Billy says her
brother Phineas is an orange triangle
and her song bad guy is quote yellow but
also red and the number seven
and if that weren't wild enough she adds
quote it smells like cookies that is
wild oh and here's a little bonus fact
for you in a behind-the-scenes video
from her Rolling Stones shoot Billy
revealed she is a super fan of the
office I just started watching it the
13th time all around all the way through
13th time has just begun me too girl
me too of course will be here to bring
you all the latest Billy Eilish news so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]